Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
And today we are without lab coats.
Well, we've got these
lovely things instead.
That's true.
We're also without our phones.
So there's no microphones, but hopefully
that one's doing all right.
We're here at the
Colorado School of Mines.
And what are we going to be doing, Daniel?
Well, when you're mining you need to use
explosives a lot of the time, right?
So that's what we're going to be doing.
We're going to be--
It's quicker than a shovel.
Exactly, except for instead of using it
for mining, we're gonna be using it
for Slow Mo Guys purposes.
Which involves a toilet,
a safe, some mannequins.
Some mannequins, some mannequins
are gonna bite it.
Plenty of explosives.
We also have an absolute
myriad of Phantoms
to get absolute range of
resolution and frame rates.
So let's have a blast.
Because of the puns and stuff.
I've destroyed a few bogs in my time.
You do like real spicy food.
It's true.
But now we're literally
gonna destroy a bog.
Kay, right?
This is pretty savage.
So we're gonna have det cord coming around
and up into the system, which is gonna be
full of petrol.
And then the detonation train will go
down here, into this
5 pound booster charge
of high explosives, which is gonna
detonate and cause a shock wave,
and hopefully destroy the bog.
So you've taken care of all the
explosive putting.
And over here in this
giant metal protective box,
we've got to Phantom v2512's.
This one is set to 28,500 frames a second.
This one is set to
207,000 frames a second.
So it's very low resolution,
but very, very fast.
Also, up there in that
yellow box we've got a v2640,
which will be HD, about
12,000 frames a second.
All right, let's watch that back.
Whoa!
Oh, where's the toilet?
I don't see a single piece.
Not one piece, mate.
I just saw a big, white, bright flash.
It was so bright.
Maybe it went out the back?
Whoa!
And all this white cloud here
is all petrol.
So did we not see it from the other
angle because the cloud covered it,
and now we're seeing the fireball here?
Yeah, I think well maybe
it just went up.
Look at it all lighting up now.
Damn!
It looks cool!
Look at all this!
All of that is lighting up now.
Look at it expand!
Oh man, it's so scary.
I'll tell you what, the dynamic range
on this camera is not bad.
Like it's pretty much held all of those
highlights, even though we're at
such a high ISO.
You know what's also really cool is
often you don't see a
big flaming explosion
with rubble going everywhere.
It's often just a flaming explosion.
Whereas this, you've got pieces of toilet
and shrapnel.
Well that's where the toilet was.
It's, I think there's no
pieces of it left.
It's literally dust.
It has been entirely eviscerated.
It's dug pretty much a crater and
cleared the area of stones completely.
So this is up there with those guys.
Whoa!
Oh!
And I'm touching it.
Cheers for that!
Next experiment.
This is the beefiest safe we could find
for $150.
I think it's about 150 years old as well.
I like that we paid $150
for a safe that doesn't work.
Yeah!
We're just trying to get into the safe.
Like, if you imagine you're a bank robber.
We're gonna just try and blow a hole
through the door.
Yeah, this safe seems to have lost
most of its concrete.
But we've got this barrel here to see,
hopefully we'll see it come into that.
So what we've got here is a shaped charge.
It looks funny because it's got a
copper cone inside.
And packed in behind the copper cone
is explosives.
This is the det cord.
It's what we'll use to initiate it.
So the explosion will come down the
det cord, down here, hit the back
of the shaped charge.
And the explosion, the
detonation will start
at the back and travel forwards.
And what that will do is force this
copper cone into an inverse jet.
So the back part here, right at the back,
will come out here before this part
even gets hit, and it'll form a jet.
And that's used to penetrate things like
tank's armor, or safes
or anything like that.
And the correct, you
have to have something
called standoff, and that's six times the
diameter of the cone, which means that
that's about 23
centimeters, 24 centimeters
away from what you're gonna penetrate.
Because that's, the width
is about 4 centimeters.
So if you had it too close.
If you had it too close, it wouldn't
be as efficient.
The copper jet wouldn't have reached
peak, like penetration capability.
Never seen a shaped charge
in slow mo.
Neither have I, actually.
Not like a, not properly.
Because they're usually part of a--
Whoa!
What?
That was absolutely instant!
All right, wind that back.
Hold on.
It's honestly like when a
meteor enters the atmosphere.
And you're just watching a big ball of
light coming through the air.
It's the same sort of speed
as well, I feel like.
The copper's already gone
into the water, and then when we spin on
you'll see that miles later
the barrel comes up.
Oh, I just love how directional
this explosive is.
And that's what it does, its job.
Literally nothing went anywhere else.
No.
Oh perfect, look at that!
Oh, hang on.
So it went into the barrel,
but it didn't come out the other side.
Which means there must be some copper
at the bottom.
That was it, straight through.
But it's annihilated all
the concrete around it.
It's like, do you see
all this concrete here?
That was in the safe.
And this rock is completely
hanging off of it,
a perfect little hole
Oh man!
Look at that!
I know we say this a lot, but
like it's nothing!
It just, eh excuse me, solid metal.
Did I just go through something?
So all of the shaped charges I've used
before in the military have been
solid copper lining.
Whereas this is an oil
and gas shaped charge,
and it's actually made of copper powder.
So there won't be any solid bits of
copper anywhere.
And you can see here that's what that is.
That's the smattering of copper powder.
And before, when it's used against tanks
and things, you can
actually see the copper
that's left over in the hole it makes.
Because it's solid copper.
So we've got Doris and Frank here,
who are retired mannequins.
Well I've noticed that Doris'
finger's come off.
Yeah, that's why she was retired.
She had an industrial accident.
This is a shock tube, and it has inside,
it's called a dust explosion,
which travels down the tube at about
2,000 meters a second.
And that's enough to initiate a detonator,
which is then enough to initiate det cord.
It's what it's used for.
But what we're gonna do is trail it
all the way from where we are,
all the way down, swirling around.
It's gonna come to Doris here.
We're gonna wrap it all
the way around Doris
like this, down to the bottom,
where we're gonna hit a detonator
into some det cord, which is then gonna
wrap all the way back around her,
around her here.
And then that will actually explode and
hopefully sort of obliterate her.
Because this is just sort of quite safe.
It won't do anything to her.
And then the det cord, this is quite long,
is gonna travel from her neck all the way
down to here, where we're gonna have a
shaped charge, which is then gonna go
through, what was his name, Frank?
Through Frank, yeah.
Frank, through Frank.
And then we've got some
foam castors on the
other side that'll hopefully explode
when the copper jet
manages to get through him.
So this is a huge chain reaction
of a bunch of different
types of explosives.
It's an explosive train,
is what it's called.
So you start small with
something like this.
Then you go into prime explosives with a
detonator, and then into det cord,
and then into a main charge.
So this time I'm going to set the
exposure on the Phantom to much lower
so we don't get as much whiteout from the
det cord explosions.
Get more detail, yeah?
[Chatter]
Don't look up her skirt!
I was looking into her finger!
How am I gonna look up
her skirt from here?
Dan, this is a special occasion
because we've got a return of a
very rare guest to Slo Mo Guys.
It's Other Dan!
It's Rival Dan!
This is a little bit
of an awkward situation
having both of us here at the same time.
You may not recognize Dan
because in this video he has his
shirt on for once.
[screaming]
Explosives and bare chest
just doesn't work out.
So then, this one here
will be edge where we
start from, and that
will go up the stairs.
See this little symbol here?
That's where we're gonna pop the det cord,
in that little cradle.
So it's enough explosive force to initiate
the shaped charge, which is gonna
blast its way through Frank.
This is an absolute operation.
It's just so nerve-wracking to watch.
You have det cord on your head basically.
I mean, it's perfectly safe.
You can chew it, and it
wouldn't do anything.
I had a taste earlier.
It's called secondary explosive.
Better to be safe than sorry!
I think so!
That's the shock tube right there.
Whoa, it's racing along!
It's so quick!
It looks fake, doesn't it?
It's gotta be like a little
disco happening here.
Whoa, I like the little,
what the?
Whoa!
It's like she's in the most
dangerous nightclub ever.
Do you think that the dec cord,
because it was wrapped
so tight around the head,
it all just went at once around the head?
Yes, because it'd be sympathetic
detonation, so one of
the layers would have
got the next one.
The shaped charge beats the shock wave.
Yeah, it's insane.
I deliberately made this one
much, much darker because we're
shooting much slower.
But we should actually see the shock tube
travel almost at a leisurely pace
at this frame rate.
Oh, here we go.
It's gone down the legs.
It should be coming any second.
Where are we?
Oh, there we go.
I think it's just, whoa!
Yes, whoa!
Oh!
The step-up in speed is so insane
because you see the shock tube going only
2,000 meters a second,
but the det cord is then
going at 7,000.
It's a huge step up.
And that shaped charge, that looks like a
damn rocket going off.
It's going about 10,000 meters a second.
And when you were describing the
shaped charge, I thought
it'd be more like a
shotgun, where it would just kind of
blow all in one direction.
But it's so narrow and so specific.
Like you could shoot someone with it!
Yeah, for sure.
You could shoot it right at someone,
and it might miss.
It's like a needle,
it's like an explosive needle.
Oh, there's her hand.
That was that good hand.
Oh, was that her safe hand?
That's a shame.
She's had a hell of a retirement
right there.
Look at what it's done to her dress?
The det cord's just like crisped it up.
De-dressed.
Look what the shaped charge did
to this guy.
It completely sawed him in half.
Totally--
Honestly, when I saw him in half here,
I thought that this
part had just come off.
Yeah, same!
But it's still connected.
Actually it's still connected.
This is just loose.
It's just taken him in half.
Here's all the foam.
That caught fire.
Oh yeah.
No, it didn't actually
get the other one, though.
Look, it didn't get that one.
It just completely blew his front out.
His front fell off.
To get Doris' head to fall off by
wrapping it in det cord.
And I saw it from over there pop up about
30, 40 feet.
And then it landed just here.
Her head's intact.
Oh, it blew one of her eye socket's off.
Oh no!
Oh, it's gruesome.
A splintered sever.
You should keep that.
The head?
Yeah.
Use it as like a--
I mean surely, though, if I try and
take it home, when they try and swab it
they'd be like
I think there's a small amount of
explosives there.
So you just say to TSA just like,
well yeah, it blew up.
Yeah, yeah.
It blew up, obviously.
Are you using this as another
opportunity to blow up some of our merch?
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, it's a woman!
Blur it out!
Oh, dear!
This is a nice t-shirt, right?
Get a rough ride out of
this, are you kidding?
I'm happy with this.
All right, looks like we're good.
What do you think?
It's lovely.
So we've made what can only be described
as a monstrosity, or some
sort of secret weapon.
Let me talk you through this.
We've got an Avalauncher.
These are used to fire into avalanches,
into snow, sorry, to force an avalanche
so it's not dangerous.
That leads down into this huge, fat tube,
which reaches all the
way down to the floor,
which is filled full of
ammonium nitrate fuel oil.
Granular, they look like what you fill a
bean bag with, except they explode.
That's exactly what it looks like.
And then around behind it, you've got two
5 pound boosters.
And this is all connected
with about 6 feet
of det cord.
So it's about 50 or more pounds of
explosives here.
We've also put a third mannequin up
in the back.
Yeah, we tried to put her back there
just to see what the
effects were, compared to,
obviously this guy's
gonna get eviscerated.
And I think that one's
probably not gonna see
much else either.
And that one, I wonder
how much will be left.
All right, let's get the hell
out of here.
Do you remember how
this place used to look
before we did that experiment?
Oh!
Look at the back wall!
It's just painted!
All right, hold on, hold on, guys.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
It's just like there's
been a hurricane here.
Yeah, it just blew everything away.
Look at the camera!
Oh god!
Oh my god!
We've got a Phantom down.
Jesus, so it blew the window open!
Look, it blew the window out!
No way!
It shot the Phantom onto the ground!
In the whole of Slow Mo Guys, that's
never happened.
Do you think we have the
footage for that?
I hope so!
Whoa!
Whoa, back there, it looked like a nuke.
It was so bright initially,
you couldn't see anything.
Like how would you expose
for that initial explosion?
Uh, you could do it, but you probably
wouldn't see anything to start with.
Oh, that looks like the end
of the world!
Oh, you can see.
Oh, there's like sparks,
sparks and flashes from the, or is it just
rock or maybe fast-moving
plastic, fast enough
where it's actually igniting on impact.
It honestly looks like that was fired
from a Fat Man.
It does!
That's what it looks like, from Fallout.
And then, once you see the
shockwave go up, you see it moving across
all this floor back here.
See, it's gone up there, and then it's
lifting up all of the dirt.
And it's imploding back down.
There's the shockwave camera, yeah.
That might be one of the best and most
well-defined shockwaves I've ever seen.
It looks like a pyroclastic flow
from the volcano.
It's just water.
And then, through the
window, bash the camera
out onto the floor.
I can't think of any time that
I would have seen any explosion that was
that big, that close.
I've certainly never seen
anything like that.
So this is the explosion-proof
camera shelter.
I feel like they've
never done an explosion
this big here.
I feel like they've
definitely never done it.
It's just knocked everything miles.
We were like this.
We were like, hey, it can get bigger.
Look what it did to this housing!
No way!
It's blown it in, it's like
crippled it front-ways.
Look at that!
It was there, and it shoved it.
It's like ripped it like a tin can.
What is interesting is that
it shocked mud so far.
Like look at our old barrel with the
hole in it.
Look at where that was.
Oh, it's got another hole in it.
Right, so think that even here,
you would have been
absolutely murdered by that.
So the 2640, which was up on the hill,
it also got caked in mud.
From all the way up there!
I wonder how quickly the mud caked the
view of the camera there.
Oh, we can see.
I put such a wide lens on it.
This is the left-hand mannequin
that was here.
It was previously about here.
That was the one that
wasn't the closest.
Yeah.
And he's turned to paste.
I honestly don't know if we can show this.
This is a bit graphic.
But look, so this lady
was stood here about,
I don't know, 5, 6 meters away.
She got picked up by the explosion
about another 4 meters back.
Her leg's off, both her arms are off.
That just shows the massive
amount of difference
between evisceration, a couple bits left
and then like, you know, most of it left.
I can't believe it blew in our
safety shelter.
It's because he put the
charge behind the water.
That's the thing.
In EOD it's called a disruptor.
You place explosive charges behind water,
and it basically just messes up everything
that's in front of the
water really quickly.
So he's placed the
charge behind the water.
And the water's just gone
straight into the camera shelter..
And that's what's done that.
Let's try and find a piece
of your Slow Mo Guys shirt.
This is it!
Oh, is that it?
That's it.
It's like coated the,
it's the Rooster Teeth.
Hold that up, that's great.
Look at that, it's the
Rooster Teeth thing.
I don't know, it's Ter Teeth.
Ter Teeth!
Well.
Do you know what my least favorite part of
every Slow Mo Guys video is?
What's that?
Well, apart from me being hurt,
is cleaning up afterwards.
But all we've left today
is a smoking crater.
Well, and there's like bits of jeans,
and plastic and stuff.
Hey, shh.
There's no plastic.
It's just burned jeans.
That might be one of
the most mental videos
we've ever made.
It's insane.
I have to tell you, that
was a lot of explosives.
Yeah.
Well, big thanks to Vision Research for
setting this up and letting
us use their Phantoms
in an extremely dangerous environment.
And thanks to the Colorado School of Mines
for letting us come
and blow stuff up here.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to follow us on
social media and stuff.
Subscribe to Slow Mo Guys.
And we got a second channel.
We'll see you next time.
I feel like the next
video should be really
relaxing, in comparison to this.
Yeah, I think we need
something like just chill.
Because this was a lot.